warning for Holiday Travelers it could
be tough very tough to get to where you
want to go this holiday season we're in
for some nasty weather all across a
major section of the country we're
talking rain we're talking snow we're
talking bitter cold a blast of it over
the next several days and the timing is
incredible and not in a good way with
nearly 113 million Americans expected to
travel for these holidays more than a
third of the country Chris Van Cleave is
at Washington's Reagan National Airport
for US you got there okay are other
people going to get where they want to
go Chris good morning
good morning that really depends on when
you leave take United Airlines alone
they have issued travel waivers for more
than 140 cities more than 140 because of
this storm the thought was that Thursday
and Friday were going to be the two
busiest days of this holiday season to
fly the message now is leave today if
you can
this morning the storm that made driving
dangerous in the Pacific Northwest
pretty icy and pretty slick yeah super
it's like it was going like this and
canceled about 200 flights in and out of
Seattle's airport Tuesday is just
getting started
the system is now lining up to bring
crippling snow and frigid temperatures
to Major Midwest airport hubs in Detroit
Minneapolis and Chicago I really don't
want to miss Christmas with my two boys
and my husband Kelsey Hicks is trying to
beat the storm that could steal
Christmas she's at a conference in
Chicago and moved up her flight to
Thursday morning hoping to beat the snow
and get back to her family in Arkansas
I'm a little nervous that things aren't
going to work out like I hope they would
165 million Americans Coast to Coast are
in the path of this blast of winter
weather hitting just days before
Christmas I'm glad I'm leaving today
dumping snow in the Midwest and we'll
head as far south as Texas just as an
estimated 113 million are expected to
travel for the holidays
if you're flying be prepared to be
delayed disrupted and canceled and
Christmas dinner may be at an airport
but most Americans will be hitting the
road with nearly 102 million expected to
be driving including Mike Carter's son
who's trying to beat the storm home to
Chicago
and anything to happen to our holiday
plans that's that's the whole scary part
otherwise we'll have about 10 tons of
food at home with nobody to eat it
why is it so significant that a storm is
barreling down on Chicago it is a huge
connecting Hub three of the nation's
biggest Airlines have hubs at airports
there United over Thanksgiving said
roughly one in five of all of its
passengers passed through Chicago so
we're talking about a ripple effect that
will stretch Coast to Coast Gail
Chris thank you not the news most people
want to hear today